OK, so Arizona's a very interesting state
since the passing of the late John McCain.
Martha McSally was appointed as senator there.
She has never won a campaign, but she's running
to keep her seat in November.
She's running against or running against her,
I think is better the right way to say it
is Democratic challenger Mark Kelly.
Mark Kelly is a former astronaut, twin brother
of Scott Kelly, who's been a guest on this
program in a new poll out of Arizona.
Mark Kelly is ahead of Martha McSally by 13
points.
On an average in recent polling, Mark Kelly
is ahead by nine points.
Now let's look at prior results in Arizona.
In 2012, Republican Jeff Flake defeated the
Democratic challenger, Richard Carmona by
three in 2016.
John McCain won in Arizona by 13, although
admittedly that the numbers are complicated
by the fact that there was a three way race.
The Green Party candidate got about 6 percent
and presumably most of that 6 percent came
from the Democratic candidate.
So McCain won by 13, could have been more
like seven.
Had there been no Green Party candidate right
now, the Republican incumbent in Arizona is
down by 13 to Mark Kelly.
So what's interesting is to look not just
at the Senate numbers in Arizona, but also
look at the presidential numbers in the same
poll where Martha McSally is down 13 to Mark
Kelly.
Joe Biden is ahead of Donald Trump by seven
in Arizona, 50 to 43.
Now, we want to be careful with these numbers.
50 plus 43 is 93.
That leaves 7 percent either undecided or
third party.
A lot of that 7 percent could break for Trump.
And then you would have a real race in Arizona.
But it could also reverse.
Right, if the economy does not improve.
If the corona virus continues to run rampant,
it could go more in Biden's favor.
At the same time, if November sees us with
a lull in Corona virus, maybe between waves
one and two, or with an economy that is looking
better, it could end up looking far better
for Donald Trump.
These are just bad numbers for Trump and Martha
McSally today.
In 2016, Trump won Arizona by about three
and a half.
So Biden plus seven is a ten point swing in
the other direction.
Now, why do we care so much about Arizona?
Arizona?
You know, it's a relatively small state.
It's only eleven electoral votes.
Why does Arizona matter so much?
What you have to understand.
Is that elections rarely go as 50 completely
isolated elections, where what happens in
Arizona has nothing to do with what happens
in Wisconsin or in Michigan, for example,
if you see a big reversal in one place.
Often there will be a number of other places
where you will see a move in the same direction.
When you look at Trump's path to victory,
all paths to victory reasonably assume that
he has to hold Arizona and probably he has
to hold Florida.
Florida, Florida's a very big question mark
for Donald Trump right now, particularly with
older voters getting away from Trump and going
in the direction of Joe Biden.
If Trump doesn't get Florida, Arizona is essentially
a must win.
And in just about every scenario, Arizona
becomes a must win in addition to Wisconsin,
Michigan, Pennsylvania, North Carolina.
Trump can win 270 electoral votes without
Arizona, but it's really, really tough.
And if Trump does lose Arizona, you have to
imagine it's not just that he loses Arizona.
He probably loses something else from 2016
as well.
This is why looking at the Senate race matters
so much.
Biden plus seven over Trump.
Maybe you believe it.
Maybe you don't.
Mark Kelly plus 13 over incumbent Republican
Senator Martha McSally.
Even if the lead is only half of that, a Democratic
challenger knocking out an incumbent Republican
senator in Arizona by 6 or 7, which is half
of what this last poll says.
That does not bode well for Republicans in
general and it would not bode well for Donald
Trump in Arizona as well.
Really interesting race to look at.
And we're going to follow it.
In 2018, six out of 10 federal offices in
Arizona went to Democrats.
That could be the turning point year in Arizona
for the red blue balance in that state.
And, of course, Mark Kelly is no progressive
hero, but he is so much better than Martha
McSally.
And it would be a big win in terms of just
their politics as well.
Monday is Memorial Day.
It's the first day off for The David Pakman
Show outside of weekends in four or five months.
We've been going hard with Corona virus.
We're just at home.
So we've just been working every day.
We are going to be taking the day off, but
running a huge membership special.
One day membership special.
You've been thinking about supporting the
work we do, but the pricing has been dissuading
you.
Monday, we will email everybody on our mailing
list on our newsletter with a huge membership
discount code.
Very easy to get on the mailing list.
Just go to David Pakman dot com upper right
of the Web site type in your email address.
Monday, you will be notified about that.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this.